The Joe Rogan experience.
Um,
yeah.
I don't know of capitalism is the problems or maybe it's how people engage with
capitalism.
Maybe it's what people choose to focus on.
If you're just about acquiring wealth and money,
some people are,
yeah,
they're going to be very deeply unhappy and it's going to be this weird game of
acquiring influence and power to,
you just have this insurmountable mountain of money that you live on top of.
Right?
I don't think that's a a good way for them either.
I think if we're gonna really,
we're going to look at this country fairly.
We have to look at,
think of all the poor neighborhoods and imagine being born in those poor
neighborhoods and imagine being born in a place where there's no resources.
There's no how you live in the fucking mountains of West Virginia and was coal
mining communities or people.
It's all just mobile homes and pills and it's chaos,
but it just extreme poverty.
What do you do if you're stuck in that?
What have you,
if you're born to that clan,
that's the group you're born into,
you're,
fuck man,
you're fucked.
We have to take our resources and concentrate on parts of America the same way
we concentrate on many other problem spots in the world and look at them as
like,
hey man,
there's a spot where people are fucked.
We should unfucked them.
We should figure out a way to go into every single horrible community in this
country on this plan.
Ones that are just as bad as some of that you see in third world countries.
They exist right here in America.
Fix that.
Don't to ignore that.
That's crazy though.
If they're in Detroit,
if they're in wherever the fuck they are,
whatever,
whatever the horrible community is.
Why isn't there a concerted national effort to eliminate that?
That's a major source of crime.
It's a major source of pride.
People feel like they got fucked over in life so they want to get at you and
take from you because you've got that easy road.
Hey man,
you're born in the fucking suburbs.
Hey Man,
your mom and dad are still together.
You know?
Hey Man,
your,
your dad has a job and your mom's at home baking and show you live like a
motherfucking Norman Rockwell movie.
Fuck you man.
My Mom's on crack.
My mom's a prostitute.
My life is hell.
My Dad beats me.
I've been sexually molested since I was a little kid.
This is the reality that people exist and they don't feel like anybody's coming
to help them.
We,
we need to concentrate on that.
The government,
if the government really cares about us,
if they're really involved in social engineering and making America better
again,
make those places better.
Those are the places you need to concentrate on.
Not Tax breaks for fucking super rich corporations that get you in place.
They make enough money,
man,
that's not the problem.
The money where,
where the money goes,
what's it being allocated towards?
The biggest problem in our country is he's in impossible to escape communities.
Yes.
That's so many people just get sucked into this trap.
And for every person that gets out and becomes a basketball player or a
successful business person,
and they have this story about the poverty that they grew up and they,
they are so rare.
Yes.
And then it's not to be applauded that they got through that.
It is,
but it's more to be,
we should understand like,
hey,
we've got a real problem that we're churning out all these people that live w w
they start out in life with a massive deficit,
start out in life,
emotionally fucked,
physically abused.
They start out with everybody around them a loser.
Everybody's going to jail.
Everybody is constantly doing pills or this or that.
They're the,
it's all negative.
And to to to ask them to develop their own positive mindset uniquely in a
vacuum,
it's preposterous.
So all these pull them up by your bootstraps,
all those assholes,
hey,
you gotta pull yourself up by your bootstraps.
Like they don't even have boots,
man.
You don't understand.
Like you don't know what you're talking about.
You,
you've never seen it,
you've never been involved in that kind of poverty.
It's not fair.
It's not fair at all.
If we care about people,
that's what we should fucking care about.
Yes,
I couldn't agree more.
The number one problem,
and it's everywhere in the world,
all the,
all the crime and poverty will imagine if everyone the lowest you could live.
It's like a middle class existence.
Yes.
Boy,
everybody would all be a lot more fucking relaxed if you always had meals,
you always had food,
you always had a roof over your head.
Everyone lives Middleclass Holy Shit.
I mean obviously that's way past the expectations that we have right now for the
world because like $34,000 a year globally puts you in the world 1%.
You know what I mean?
That's the w.
If you make $34,000 a year,
which is hard to live on,
man,
you,
you're in the 1% of the world.
But that standard that you've say very eloquently described is I think
achievable and that ought be the aim.
And when you give just one example of how legislate the bias of legislation is
continually to support the powerful while making the just making nominal
gestures to poverty.
Good women.
Yeah,
middle gestures like where you put the yeah and that say that if there is a
point to nation,
if there is a point to a flag and our belief in this idea that there is in
America and there is a Britain and we're all together and we're all one and
we've got a common destiny in a common past,
then if we're not,
if we're ignoring and neglecting those communities then I say that is what
defines us.
You know,
and until there are systems codes,
regulations that prioritize that we will continue to live in something heading
to if not a dystopia.
I think moving in the direction of dystopia where the priorities and dreams are
sort of owned really by the kind of mad evil insect robot images that we've seen
discussed.
Then people do get very concerned when someone reaches a point of excessive
power and influence like a Jeff Bezos type character.
When you see some guy who's not,
he doesn't have $1 million.
Like Yo,
wow,
guys got $1 million.
Like you must be so relaxed.
It's got so much money now he's got 150 billion
and he works every day maniacally.
And he's constantly doing new projects and new things and buying out whole
foods.
And that's like pinnacle capitalism is one of the things that scares people the
most when someone just acquires
is insane position of power and wealth.
Like,
like a Bill Gates type character who is very altruistic,
very,
very generous.
Bill Gates is accused of one of the better examples of someone who gains a lot
of money and then does a lot to help people,
especially in his retirement.
All,
all they do is focus on charitable organizations and yeah,
which is brilliant.
But yeah,
and in a marvelous,
and you know,
I'm not criticizing the great achievement of brilliant people,
but like if really for me that demonstrates their limit,
that the limitations come from the type of systems we live in,
that you can't fruit charity effect every impoverished community in America.
You know,
like we,
the systems that we have are,
are,
well,
if you're poor like that,
you know,
the boot strap model,
well this guy did it.
Look at this great guy who overcame the odds,
you know,
until like,
I feel like in a sense charity has become a kind of valve that allows that,
you know,
people like you and I who aren't poor to feel like,
well I do a bit,
you know,
I'm sort of involved.
I can wash my hands with it when,
you know,
like what these,
unless we,
the reason no America,
there is no England.
Unless we have integral relationships with one another,
we support one another.
If we really are on a team,
when we see someone who's completely downtrodden,
who's on our team and we ignore them,
well that's not much of a fucking team is it?
No,
I mean that's what I feel like when it come to red lights and I see homeless
people.
I,
I feel terrible.
I'm like,
I feel like,
you know,
I mean,
there's,
part of me is like,
don't give him any money because they know they're going to just buy drugs.
You know?
Let them figure it out,
but then they're not going to figure it out.
They have mental health issues and it's done.
It's drier and they're supposedly on the team.
They probably were born in America.
They probably have national citizenship here.
You know,
they,
this is our team and no one gives a fuck.
They're camped out under the bridge.
It's like the diffusion of responsibility that comes with these massive numbers.
20 million in La,
300 and plus whatever it is now,
what?
It's like three 20 in America.
Yeah.
It sound believable.
I think there's 90,000 in the General California.
Right,
like a city's worth of homeless people,
isn't it?
It's not difficult for me to envisage that when we talk about the transcendent
states that can be achieved through meditation and Psychedelics,
meaning that beings like us can access them is not difficult to envisage humor,
like a type of creature type of being.
A little more evolved than us that we'd look back and say,
oh my God,
they allowed homelessness.
They allowed those impoverished communities or why was it oxide?
This belief in competitive systems and survival of the fittest that we're
resourced from ideas that weren't really meant to be translated into that.
When you were talking before about like the natural world is fraught with
competition and fret.
Of course there's days animals.
So you know,
I'm not disputing what you're saying there,
but we can't transpose that into an economic system.
Survival led a fist.
If you ain't got enough hustle and muscle,
fuck you.
You have to do a town by the wayside.
You know?
Here we have an obligation to aspire to the better parts of our nature.
Not to continually use materialism and rationalism to justify that 20% of the
population that you know or whatever is energy is at just garbage.
It just there.
That's affordable.
We can call,
we can live with that.
He is.
For me,
it's,
that's why would we,
once we have the knowledge that,
oh yeah,
we shouldn't be farming in that way.
Oh,
we shouldn't have social systems.
All of the,
the answer's always the same because if you were to change in that area,
it will affect the interests of the powerful,
it will affect,
impede the ability of certain organizations to make profit.
Now I'm,
you know,
I'm not talking about,
yeah,
I don't know the lexicon enough around socialism and capitalism and Marxism and
various forms of social organization.
I'm just talking about my assumption that we're all resourced from the same
basic material and phenomenal.
We all have compassion and loving us and if we on an individual level can
achieve some level of access to that,
then we can start to organize ourselves on that basis,
not on the basis of,
well,
what's the most I can get as an individual?
It's rational for me to be there.
I'm not involved in that.
That doesn't affect me personally,
you know,
and I think it's a hard thing for us to hold.
I think the reason we all do just live with homelessness and the only decision
we make is do we put a couple of dollars out the window with the light or not?
Then like big,
it's hard to hold that it's hard to love more than a hundred people.
There's no fix.
There's no as an individual,
not as not one person and even collectively as a group when you have mental
health issues,
unless you want to institutionalize those people.
Yeah,
but then who?
Here's the thing,
right?
If everyone has a unique,
and if everyone has their own ideas about what to do with their life and
everyone has freedom,
what if you just don't have enough people that are interested in,
in,
in mental health of the homeless people?
You just don't have enough.
There's no resources guarantee.
The results is,
yeah.
That's a big question because our systems are biased in a particular direction.
What if they have government funding?
Do you think that that could cure homelessness?
One of the advantages I've got
being a drug addict does it means I have to help have a drug addicts as part of
my own recovery.
This puts me into areas,
institutions,
groups,
facilities where me and drug addicts and always what?
You'll find that people that work there,
there's always someone like a man or a woman most often in my personal expenses
as a woman,
some matriarchal woman full of mother energy that just will do this shit forever
for free,
for nothing that just loves it.
Let's just put herself like my grandmother did or my mother data I'd like these
women do between people in the gutter that are just willing to say,
I'll be the person,
I'll be the person in la at friendly house.
It was a woman called Peggy all but used to run a play.
A friendly houses are for women that have got drug and addiction and abuse
issues and like this woman,
she was from Chicago,
she was 90 years old by the time like I'm actually so rude and brilliant and
beautiful and entirely willing to dedicate yourself.
And I think every community everywhere,
everyone knows people like that.
And I feel like the same way as like if it is someone who has got a great
capacity or play basketball or be a comic.
Like I think that when you spot those people that you encourage them and
talented and help them people.
Yeah.
The talent of compassion and let you know that.
But we don't value that unless it's like,
unless it can be turned to a profit fuck off.
All of those organizations like those organizations that help people with
addiction issues,
you know,
like they are maligned and like the people that profit from the opioid crisis,
they are supported.
They are able to conceal as John Oliver Brilliantly revealed.
Are they,
they're able to conceal their practices continually.
The invisible biases in the direction of profit and like the failure of certain
types of socialism doesn't mean that's the end of the argument.
I think we have an obligation to look for ways of accessing our own,
uh,
higher nature,
better nature kind of nature.
Call it what you will and seeing how we can organize that as an individual.
You can do so much.
I,
if Bill Gates can,
you know,
fucking Hell I had no cure malaria and make the significant charitable Dana,
these impressive,
powerful people can't make a meaningful difference than clearly this is a
systemic,
yeah,
problem.
Well,
there's also the problem with homeless people and that they're adults.
Um,
when you become an adult and you develop from the time you were a child,
it's probably very likely that the damage was all done while they were young.
They were probably abused and neglected and there's a lot of issues that led
them to either have mental health problems or they had mental health problems
already.
Maybe they have genetic problems.
Then on top of that,
there's drug abuse.
Do you,
for each one of those people to get well,
you're going to need a massive amount of folks.
You're not going to have one old lady who's rude.
Brilliant.
That's a cute movie,
but that's 20 people.
Yeah.
He's a good movie.
You're down.
Write it down.
Yeah.
Who would,
who would be the woman?
Faye Dunaway or some shit like the one that was a out of golden girls.
Estelle Getty.
She's still available.
I thought,
Oh God,
a wrap.
They white still around.
Betty White's still hanging in there.
Yeah.
But what'd you book a movie around her stink.
Hang on one [inaudible] yeah.
How are we going to fund this?
Yeah,
it's um,
yeah,
no you're right.
Look,
there's limitation to be individual but that there's not like crushed this
optimism in the crib now Joe.
Right.
Cause I know trashing the optimism,
but I'm saying the logistics of it would almost be insurmountable and it's very
hard to fill.
It
is not an objective thing.
It's this thing that's been biased over time.
Sort of once a person is developed once they're assuming it's very difficult to
turn that train around.
Yeah.
If we can save the community and save the future,
like help,
like less people get through fucked help,
let me help more people get through with hope and with a real possibility for
improving their life versus have this sense of hopelessness that many are
confronted with that's going to make less crime.
I agree.
That's like that's just if they,
if someone looked at it from a social engineering standpoint,
it almost seems like the only way that would ever have to happen would be
there's be some fucking catastrophe that force people to act like we sometimes
need something that's shoved in our face to force us to act,
but if someone brilliantly calculated the amount of resources that it would
require and then also brilliantly calculated how much less crime me,
we'd have,
how much less,
how many more innovations because people didn't waste their lives.
In fact,
they got through and used one of the most valuable resources we have,
which is the human imagination and creativity and ingenuity like,
and we're missing that on these people that are growing up in these horrible
environments where they can't escape.
There's so fuck from,
they're in gangs there,
you know the crime and poverty and violence,
there's so fucked that whatever genius they have is wasted on this nonsensical
existence.
If they could just show that in,
quantify how much that would be,
how valuable that would be to the overall culture and community of the co of the
continent.
And then ultimately of the earth mean do you would have a reason to engineer.
Think about that.
She has a beautiful,
that is really beautiful and it's interesting that the way that I agree with you
that it's almost has to at some point be translated into monetary value because
otherwise people
does seem to read it.
Yeah,
and safety for everybody,
for them who live in these horrible communities wouldn't be great.
Again,
if everybody lived like a middle class person,
the idea that that's impossible seems so insane.
It's almost seems like,
well then nobody should live like that.
Then like either everybody should be able to live like that or nobody should be
a little boy.
That was like,
that's what everybody really wants,
right?
You want to be comfortable like in terms of like your ability to exist and then
all the things you're doing that you struggle with should be a good percentage
of them other than emotional and friendship type thing should be of your own
choosing.
You choose to,
to take a difficult path.
You she choose to take an adventure.
You choose to try to enrich yourself with this difficult experience and the
challenge of it and try to overcome that challenge instead of you.
Your challenge is not to get killed by a gang.
You know,
your,
your challenge is not get fucked by your uncle again.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
this is what people have to deal with and you're,
you're missing these brilliant minds.
They don't get this chance to come through and,
and sneak through that fucking salmon ladder.
You know,
get up to the top.
This would be a very beautiful,
that you are passionate about this.
And I think popularizing these ideas is important because I feel that then
people will be familiar with this kind of language and we'll recognize that when
there is political discourse.
How phatic an empty he yeah.